Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
J’ai été invité, car j’ai installé
sur les murs de l’INSA de Rouen
un grand collage, un dessin qui recouvre
l’entrée de l’école d’ingénieurs
que j’ai nommé « La Chute »,
qui représente une chute d’Icare,
que les étudiants de l’INSA
de Rouen ont sûrement vu.
On y voit Dédale, le père d’Icare,
qui était ingénieur,
tenter de rattraper son fils
par un bout de tissu.
Et on comprend qu'il n'y parviendra pas.
Ça m’amusait d’installer cette histoire
à l’entrée d’une école d’ingénieurs,
un peu comme une sorte
de petite piqûre de rappel.
C’était un peu ça l’idée,
c’est-à-dire dessiner un ingénieur
qui voit son fils mourir
à cause d’une invention
qu’il a lui-même créée.
On m’a dit que le thème de la conférence
tournait autour de l’ennemi intérieur
ou de l’ennemi commun.
Je voudrais montrer que notre ennemi,
celui qui veut nous nuire,
c’est d’abord nous-mêmes
dans ce temps présent,
c’est notre manque de mesure
que symbolise Icare.
Manque de mesure qui vient
du fait que nous nous sommes perdus dans
une unique manière de voir les choses,
celle de l’homme moderne,
celle de l’ingénieur.
J’aime à me rappeler qu’on pourrait
voir le monde autrement,
c’est-à-dire comme un artiste, comme
un philosophe ou comme un amoureux.
On pourrait se demander si la modernité
ne nous a pas fait perdre la vue,
c’est-à-dire si elle ne nous a pas fait
passer finalement d’un regard à l’autre.
On pourrait dire que, dans mon parcours,
je suis passé d’un regard à l’autre.
J’ai d’abord fait des études de physique,
puis je suis devenu
enseignant de philosophie,
et aujourd’hui, je suis street artist
sous le nom de Gaspard Lieb.
J’aimerais bien raconter cette histoire.
J’étais à un concert et je regardais
des jeunes gens faire de la musique.
En fait, ils jouaient.
Ce qui est agréable quand on est musicien,
c’est que, quand on va travailler,
on peut dire qu’on va jouer.
Je me rappelle très bien m’être dit
que c’était ça qui était important,
c’est-à-dire qu’il fallait s’évertuer
à faire des choses inutiles et belles.
Et c’est devenu mon mantra : s’évertuer
Je colle des dessins dans la rue,
pour ma part,
qui ne sont pas destinés à durer.
Ils ne peuvent pas être emportés,
ni manipulés, ni vendus.
Dans un monde technique, justement,
qui veut que tout soit manipulable,
qui veut tout s’approprier,
qui veut tout rendre disponible,
au fond, moi, je produis des objets,
dans le street art,
qui sont des choses absolument
indisponibles, absolument invendables,
des sortes de non-objets.
Si vous voulez prendre un de
mes dessins installés dans la rue,
il se déchirera, il se détruira,
c’est-à-dire que le manipuler
ou le prendre, c’est le perdre.
Ils peuvent donc n’être
au fond que regardés.
C’est de ça dont on n’a plus l’habitude,
cette manière d’être.
On voit les choses,
mais on ne les contemple plus vraiment.
Bien souvent, on voit les choses
sans les regarder.
Je me rappelle avoir vendu
un dessin à une dame
et lui avoir expliqué qu’elle pouvait
voir mes dessins dans la rue.
Sur le conservatoire de Rouen, il y a
un énorme dessin qui fait 6,20 de haut,
juste à l'entrée du conservatoire.
Et la dame me dit : « J’emmène ma fille
toutes les semaines au Conservatoire,
je ne l’ai jamais vu. »
On peut se demander comment
elle a pu ne pas le voir,
En fait,
parfois, on ne voit pas les choses parce
qu’on passe à côté ou on regarde ailleurs,
un peu comme cette dame,
mais parfois plus fondamentalement,
parce que ce que nous voyons, ce ne sont
plus que des signes conventionnels,
qui nous permettent de reconnaître l’objet
pour pouvoir simplement le manipuler.
On voit une chaise, on voit un mur,
on voit la porte d’entrée du Conservatoire
de Rouen, par exemple,
on voit un passant
qui passe et qu’on évite,
mais est-ce qu’on a vraiment vu
le bois de la chaise ?
Est-ce qu’on a vraiment vu
la matière du mur qu’on regardait ?
Est-ce qu’on a vraiment vu le visage
du passant qu’on a évité ?
En fait, non.
On a vu souvent un passant qui passe.
On a vu la porte d’entrée
du Conservatoire.
C’est-à-dire on a rien vu [d’autre]
qu’un monde fonctionnel,
un monde silencieux.
Un monde qui, globalement,
ne nous parle plus.
Un monde qui, au fond,
est devenu totalement muet.
On pourrait très bien
aller plus loin et dire que,
lorsque nous regardons
les choses de cette manière,
nous les réduisons
ou nous les dévisageons ;
au sens propre, nous les défigurons.
La nature, aujourd’hui, n’est regardée
que comme un capital disponible,
un stock de matières premières.
Je voulais vous montrer une petite image,
mais je ne peux pas.
Comme un stock de matières premières.
Exactement comme ça.
La forêt amazonienne,
aujourd’hui, pour l’industriel,
c’est un stock de meubles disponibles.
La même forêt est un stock
de médicaments potentiels
pour l’industrie pharmaceutique.
Et la même forêt est un stock
ou une surface agricole disponible
pour l’agriculteur, etc. etc.
Mais au fond,
plus personne ne voit la forêt.
D’ailleurs, à force de ne plus la voir,
elle disparaît.
En fait, si elle disparaît,
c'est qu'elle a déjà disparu
dans notre regard.
Si on défigure les bords de mer
avec des complexes touristiques,
c’est qu’ils ne sont déjà plus
des bords de mer, en un sens,
mais un stock de loisirs disponibles
que l’on doit justement rendre
disponibles et utilisables.
Et c’est ce regard au fond
notre ennemi intérieur,
c’est-à-dire celui qui
va finir par nous nuire,
ce regard qui réduit en fait
les choses à l’utile
et, fondamentalement,
qui en perd la beauté.
C’est celui de l’homme moderne qui,
constamment, arraisonne les choses,
pour reprendre un concept que je vole
à Heidegger, un philosophe du XXe siècle.
« Arraisonner »,
c’est un terme peu courant,
c’est un mot de pirate ou de gendarme,
mais c’est l’essence même
de la technique moderne.
Quand la police arraisonne un navire,
elle lui demande ses raisons,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle contrôle
ses papiers, sa cargaison,
elle lui demande : « Pourquoi tu es là ?
Quelle est ta raison d’être ? »
Et en fait, tu dois avoir
une raison d’être là, une fonction.
Mes élèves en début d’année me demandent :
« A quoi ça sert la philosophie ? »
C’est une question typiquement moderne,
typiquement technique.
En fait, la technique nous demande
constamment nos papiers.
C’est ça « arraisonner ».
Le technicien ne supporte pas
les sans-papiers.
Il ne supporte pas non plus
les choses inutiles et belles.
Il faut que la forêt ait une fonction,
que la montagne ait
une utilité pour nos loisirs,
que mon travail ait
une utilité économique.
Mais si on y regarde bien,
les ours polaires par exemple,
ils ne servent à rien.
Ils sont sans-papiers.
On pourrait dire aujourd’hui
qu’ils sont absolument inessentiels.
Alors, est-ce qu’on doit dire :
« Tant pis pour eux !
Ils n’avaient qu’à servir
à quelque chose. »
On s’est mis à se préoccuper des abeilles
parce qu’on a pris conscience qu’elles
avaient une fonction vitale pour nous.
Mais je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit un bon argument.
Est-ce qu’il faudrait que
toute chose ait une fonction ?
Est-ce qu’il faut trouver une fonction
aux vieux, aux handicapés, aux chômeurs
pour s’en préoccuper ?
Vous voyez bien que si ce regard technique
se porte sur d’autres êtres humains,
alors ça devient choquant, voire immoral.
Et si notre rapport au monde
était uniquement technique,
alors la seule valeur,
ce serait l’utilité,
c’est-à-dire l’utilité d’une chose
ou l’utilité d’une personne.
Je ne vais pas dire, par exemple,
à mon amoureuse
que je l’aime parce qu’elle m’est utile.
Vous voyez bien que
ça va créer un conflit de couple.
que ça ne va pas être possible.
En fait, on peut se demander si,
justement, ce qui vaut le plus,
ce n’est pas justement
ce qui ne sert à rien.
Un bon repas entre amis, typiquement,
ça ne sert à rien.
Se baigner dans la mer, ça ne sert à rien.
Faire un jeu, faire un foot avec
ses proches, ça ne sert à rien.
Faire l’amour, ça ne sert à rien,
Ce n’est pas du tout rentable.
On a une activité érotique
typiquement parce qu’elle nous
apporte du bonheur en elle-même.
Ce n'est pas un moyen,
c'est une fin en soi.
On le fait pour le faire
et c’est peut-être là qu’on reconnaît
les choses qui nous font vraiment plaisir.
Elles sont sans but.
Le bonheur, au fond, ça ne sert à rien.
Ce n’est pas très rentable, et pourtant,
c’est ce que nous cherchons tous.
Je ne dis pas qu’il ne faut faire
que des choses inutiles et belles.
Ce serait absurde.
Je dis que toutes les autres choses
que l’on fait,
on les fait peut-être parce
qu’elles sont des moyens
pour atteindre cet inutile,
pour atteindre ce moment où on est là
en résonance avec le monde,
pour reprendre le vocabulaire d’Hartmut
Rosa, un sociologue contemporain.
Au fond, notre ennemi, dans ce cas-là,
c’est cet oubli,
cet oubli qu’il y a
un autre regard possible,
un autre rapport aux choses que
celui uniquement technique et utilitaire.
Au fond, c’est ce que font les artistes.
Les Grecs, par exemple, pensaient
la production comme poièsis,
c’est-à-dire comme poésie,
comme dévoilement des choses.
Si vous prenez un poète,
il produit un poème,
mais son œuvre sert
à dévoiler ce qu’est l’amour,
à dévoiler ce qu’est la souffrance
ou ce que c’est qu’aimer dans sa vérité.
Le photographe qui a vraiment un œil
artiste prend des photos de famille.
Au fond, ce qu’il nous donne à voir,
c’est un visage,
c’est une humanité et non une fonction,
c’est-à-dire pas un ouvrier,
pas un ingénieur, pas un client.
Finalement, il essaie de dévoiler
l’être humain derrière la fonction.
De la même manière, on pourrait penser
que les bons techniciens
ou les bons agriculteurs - le parallèle
peut paraître bizarre -
L’agriculture biologique
ou l’agriculture raisonnée,
elle peut se donner comme but
les mêmes objectifs que ceux d’un artiste,
c’est-à-dire prendre soin,
par le technique,
de la plante elle-même ou de
la nature pour qu’elles se révèlent,
qu’elles s’épanouissent,
qu’elles se dévoilent d’elles-mêmes.
Au fond, ça pourrait être aussi un travail
poétique au sens grec du terme.
Une sorte de poésie de la nature,
c’est-à-dire travailler à la cultiver
et non pas simplement à l’exploiter.
Vous voyez que c’est assez étrange
parce que le langage courant,
il est teinté, il retient la trace de ce
rapport technique qu’on a aux choses.
On ne dit plus « cultiver »,
on dit « exploiter » la nature.
On ne parle pas de ferme,
mais d’exploitation agricole.
Vous êtes des jeunes ingénieurs qui
allez travailler dans des entreprises,
donc vous aurez affaire à des DRH,
c’est-à-dire des directeurs
de ressources humaines.
Si on entend bien le langage,
on dit que l’humain est
une ressource pour l’entreprise,
c’est-à-dire un stock
d’humains disponibles
ou de force de travail
disponible pour l’entreprise.
Alors, c’est vrai que c’est ça ;
l’employé, il est ça pour l’entreprise,
mais il n’est pas que ça.
Si on oublie qu’il est autre chose,
c’est là où ça va finir
par poser problème.
C’est là notre ennemi.
Ces deux types de regards sur le monde,
le regard technique et le regard poétique,
apparaissent comme nécessaires
et indispensables,
sinon nous chuteront comme Icare.
Alors, bien évidemment,
on ne peut pas avoir simplement un rapport
poétique ou contemplatif au monde.
Je ne vais pas demander
aux chercheurs de Pfizer
de contempler poétiquement la Covid-19.
Ce serait suicidaire, ce serait
contempler poétiquement la mort.
Et ce serait stupide.
Le poète seul, si vous voulez,
ne survivra pas sans le technicien,
mais de la même manière,
la technique seule est tout aussi stupide,
voire peut-être barbare.
C’est ce que Michel Henry
appelle la barbarie.
Quand l’économie n’est que finance,
quand l’art n’est plus vu que comme
une marchandise ou un placement,
quand la nature n’est plus
qu’une réserve de minerai,
quand la pensée n’est plus
que simplement un calcul,
c’est ça, la barbarie.
Calculer, c’est bien, mais vous voyez
que ce n’est pas à un mathématicien
que vous demanderez le sens
de votre vie ou de votre action.
Le mathématicien, il vous dira
comment maximiser votre action,
comment la faire plus efficacement,
mais pas pourquoi la faire.
Au fond, le Zyklon B,
c’est un problème de chimie calculable
pour un chimiste ;
la bombe atomique simplement un problème
de physique calculable pour un ingénieur.
Vous voyez que la barbarie
n’est donc pas la sauvagerie.
Le barbare, c’est celui
qui s’enferme dans son calcul,
mais du coup,
qui ne voit plus ce qu’il fait.
C’est la raison qui optimise
le fonctionnement des chambres à gaz,
c’est-à-dire les plus hautes facultés
de l’homme
au service de la destruction de l’homme.
C’est un bulldozer hydraulique ultra
moderne qui détruit la forêt amazonienne.
Au fond, c’est Icare, le fils d’ingénieur,
courant à sa perte.
À ce moment, donc, on comprend bien
qu’il faut arrêter sa course
comme Icare, finalement,
aurait dû le faire,
pour se demander pourquoi l’on calcule
et qu’est-ce que l’on veut produire.
Ne pas vouloir prendre ce temps,
c’est là encore notre ennemi.
L’efficacité de la technique,
elle nous a donné le vertige
parce qu’effectivement, ça marche
et ça marche très, très bien.
Et du coup, notre propre réussite
nous a sûrement gonflés d’orgueil.
En fait, nous voilà
nous-mêmes devenus Icare.
Et c’est là le troisième ennemi intérieur
que je voulais définir : l’orgueil.
Toujours ce rapport à la technique.
Premièrement, on s’est enfermé
dans un mode d’être,
dans un regard sur le monde
uniquement technique.
On ne voit les choses que comme
des moyens ou des fonctions utiles.
Deuxièmement, on a été pris
dans l’engrenage et la vitesse
du progrès technique,
qui ne nous laisse finalement
plus le temps de réfléchir
au sens de ce que l’on fait.
On a produit la 4G, bientôt la 5G,
bientôt la 15G peut-être.
On pourrait se dire : « Mais pourquoi ? »
Est-ce que quelqu’un pense sérieusement
que la 5G va le rendre plus heureux ?
Je ne dis pas que ça ne va pas
être commode ou utile,
c’est-à-dire on va trouver plein d’usages
de la 5G ou même de la 15G,
mais je parle ici de bonheur,
c’est-à-dire est-ce que
ça va me rendre plus heureux ?
Sûr, ça va être incroyable ;
peut-être qu’un jour, on pourra faire
des trucs qu’on n’imagine même pas,
et cette efficacité
risque de me gonfler d’orgueil,
un orgueil finalement face
à l’efficacité de cette technique.
L’histoire d’Icare est très intéressante
sur ce point.
Dédale, c’est un ingénieur de génie,
vaniteux et sans morale.
Il a conçu le labyrinthe,
vous le savez peut-être,
dans lequel on a emprisonné le Minotaure.
Il va se retrouver à son tour condamné
à être enfermé dans ce même labyrinthe.
Pour s’enfuir avec son fils,
il va construire des ailes
capables de les faire voler
tous les deux comme des oiseaux.
Mais Icare va oublier
les conseils de son père
et, enivré par ce pouvoir de la technique,
il va se prendre peut-être même
pour un Dieu.
Vous le savez tous, il va voir fondre ses
ailes en s’approchant trop près du soleil.
On voit bien que Dédale, il a donné
à son fils l’instrument de sa perte.
Il lui a donné la puissance,
mais Icare n’avait pas la mesure,
et Dédale ne pourra rien faire
pour sauver son fils.
Pour les Grecs, l’ennemi intérieur,
c’est d’abord seulement l’orgueil,
l’orgueil humain, l’excès,
ce qu’ils appellent l’hubris.
Et donc le manque de mesure,
et non la technique elle-même.
Ici, pour les Grecs,
nous sommes notre propre ennemi.
Ils avaient l’idée que la sagesse,
elle était essentiellement dans la mesure.
En fait, ça, ça n’a pas changé.
Mais quelque chose a fondamentalement
changé à l’époque moderne,
c’est qu’on a pris
la technique et la science
pour la seule sagesse possible,
pour la seule manière de voir
et de mesurer les choses.
Regardez par exemple le poids
que les mathématiques ont pris
dans vos études
et dans la sélection des élites.
On sélectionne essentiellement les gens
sur leur capacité à calculer,
ce qui n’est au fond
qu’une modalité de la pensée.
Là , cet après-midi,
on ne fait pas de calcul,
mais pourtant, on pense.
La mesure ne pourrait être retrouvée
qu’en reprenant le temps de la réflexion,
une réflexion sur nos fins, et donc
en cultivant un autre type de pensée.
Pour cela, il faudrait s'extraire un
instant de la course du progrès technique.
C’est l’espoir qu’on a vu
dans le premier confinement,
on a tout arrêté, on a dit
qu’on allait penser le monde d’après.
Et en vrai, on a tout arrêté,
et on a tous regardé des séries télé,
vous comme moi, sûrement,
et pas beaucoup pensé.
Le but n’est pas d’arrêter
la technique ni le progrès.
Il est bon pour Icare de savoir voler, car
c’est ce qui va le sauver du labyrinthe.
Il est bon
de faire progresser la médecine,
ce qui va nous sortir du labyrinthe dans
lequel on est aujourd’hui avec la Covid.
Mais la question, c'est de savoir vers où
aller, vers où on utilise cette technique.
Icare, on l’a vu,
il est allé droit dans le mur.
Cela ne sera possible
qu’en nous rendant un peu plus disponible
à la réflexion
et à la contemplation du monde.
Cela nécessite finalement qu’on pose
un autre regard sur le monde,
un regard de poète peut-être,
de philosophe ou d’amoureux.
À ce moment-là , le monde nous
apparaîtra peut-être un peu plus inutile,
peut-être moins disponible,
mais sûrement bien plus beau.